people in clark county are eager to get
out and vote
polling locations have proved to be very
busy on the first weekend of early
voting
joe mohler live near tropical and
centennial center boulevard up in the
northwest valley
at what is a very busy location hi joe
hey brian that's right definitely
becoming a busy location here this is
actually the home depot parking lot
there's tent behind us here
people are waiting at this time the wait
is a little less than a half an hour
earlier today it was well over an hour
and even on saturday it was about
four hours just in the first two days
there was about three thousand people
who came out here to vote early
people say despite the wait they want to
get this done
and vote and we did our part today early
voting is well underway in southern
nevada
what a democratic processes at work you
know and america is doing their thing
and everybody gets the opportunity to
cast their vote for whoever they wish
some came back monday after a four hour
wait at the centennial hills location
saturday
it was awful and then we went to two
other locations and it was just as bad
in the first two days there were 50
thousand people who cast their ballots
in clark county
it's exciting to see everybody as an
american
getting out and doing what they're
supposed to do
vote people say they prefer to get it
done early and the same thing proved
popular in previous years
in 2016 roughly 488 thousand people
voted early
in 2012 there were 436 thousand early
voters
it wasn't like this back in 2016
remember it was this this is i mean this
is shocking put it that way
for those looking to vote early the
clark county elections department does
have an interactive map with wait times
i think america is hard at work right
now
now back out here live locations are
open from nine o'clock in the morning
until 7 p.m so this one's just about
wrapping up here
early voting does end next friday the
30th reporting live in the northwest
valley joe mohler 8 news now